we have a deal on the budget for 2017  the final agreement strongly reflects  the EU s main policy priorities  migration security and investment to  boost growth and jobs at the same time  it respects member states continuing  ambition to have healthy public finances  what we did in this budget is also to  balance traditional priorities with  ability to support innovation in the end  what matters is how money is being used  and I am proud to say that it is not  only the numbers in the budget but the  quality of the programs and the emphasis  on performance in what we are funding so  I think it's it really means investing  in the future when you focus on the  youth employment initiative it's an  investment in the future when you  allocate additional funds to erasmus+ to  allow young people to move around across  the european union and strengthen  enhance their European the sense of  Europeans European citizenship